[Musique]
face à ces mobilités inédites sur le
marché du travail quelles réponses peut
apporter l'entreprise à ce malaise
grandissant chez certains salariés
Patrick Martin bonjour bonjour Merci
d'être la président délégué du Medef
quand on regarde les chiffres on voit le
nombre des ministres de démission qui
est au plus haut depuis 2008 est-ce que
vous comprenez comme ça que des gens
partent vous comprenez leur motivation
que ce soit pour des raisons de salaire
pour être mieux payés pour moins
travailler le soir le week-end d'être
mieux considéré plus de flexibilité vous
comprenez vous voyez ce qui se passe là
faut le relativiser premier point cette
thèse de la grande démission je n'y
crois pas on n'y croit pas effectivement
on est un taux de démission qui doit
être de tête de l'ordre de 2,8% qui se
compare à celui qu'on avait en 2008
époque où on ne parlait absolument pas
de grandes démission alors qu'une
mobilité accrue sur le marché de
l'emploi ça s'explique ça s'explique
parce que les entreprises recrutent
beaucoup ça crée autant d'opportunités
chaque fois qu'une personne démissionne
il faut la remplacer et puis oui quand
même il y a des comportements au travail
qui ont pu évoluer notamment pendant la
période de confinement que télétravail
ou en activité partielle mais le taux
d'emploi en France n'a jamais été aussi
élevé c'est ça qu'il faut surtout
retenir donc il y a de la mobilité avec
des revendications si on a plus on est
plus d'ailleurs les revendications des
salariés on voit la question des
rémunérations du salaire est-ce que le
patronat pardon de dire comme ça est
prêt à mettre la main à la poche parce
qu'on voit des salaires aujourd'hui en
augmentation dans les négociations
annuelles autour de 3% laflation est
assise on se dit que le contenu est pas
alors 3% c'est en moyenne des secteurs
et des entreprises ce qui a été négocié
au printemps c'était assez cohérent avec
le taux d'inflation de l'emprunt voilà
on était dans ces eaux là parce que les
NAO avait été entamé pour beaucoup
d'entre elles dès la fin de l'année 2021
alors depuis lors il y a des discussions
qui n'ont pas mal d'entreprises ont
recommencé ont pu aboutir dans un
certain nombre de cas soit sous forme
d'augmentation des salaires de base soit
à travers le versement de prime
d'ailleurs les deux sont pas alternatifs
puis il y a quand même un nouveau
facteur c'est que la conjoncture c'est
beaucoup dégradé entre temps donc des
marges de manœuvre pour les entreprises
qui finalement ne leur permettent pas
d'accompagner les salaires autant que
voudrait l'inflation même si on n'est
pas en indexation des salaires voilà et
vous ne souhaitez pas qu'on y revienne
surtout pas surtout pas parce que tous
les économistes le disent dans cette
spirale infernale salaire inflation on
l'a connu dans d'autres épaules c'est
sans fin et d'achat pour les salariés si
nécessairement pas nécessairement parce
que il va y avoir par exemple à la
rentrée
2023 cette fois il va y avoir de
nouvelles Nao on ne sait pas très bien
ce que sera l'inflation en 2023 si ça se
trouve les augmentations qui ont été
données qui ont été négociées seront
supérieurs à ce que sera l'inflation
moyenne sur l'ensemble de l'année et
pourquoi ne pas rogner un petit peu sur
les marches justement pour augmenter les
salaires pour les entreprises pendant
les moyens bien sûr pas toutes alors
c'est précisément ce que j'allais
répondre parce que les entreprises
elles-mêmes subissent l'inflation on
évoquait le prix des denrées
alimentaires actuellement on ne retrouve
pas dans les prix de vente
l'augmentation des intrants que ce soit
l'énergie la matière première les
emballages de transport etc etc donc
comment dire considérer que oui les
ménages subissent l'inflation mais les
entreprises non c'est une vue de
l'esprit et donc ça réduit à nouveau les
marges de manoeuvre de beaucoup de
secteurs d'activités quand vous êtes
actuellement par exemple dans le ciment
dans l'acier dans le papier carton dans
le verre et cetera il a travaillé vous
travaillez à perte c'est pas compliqué
vous travaillez à perdre du fait de
l'explosion du prix de l'énergie et pour
les autres secteurs alors pour les
autres secteurs il y a beaucoup
d'augmentation qui ont été consentis si
vous regardez l'augmentation de la masse
salariale sur le premier semestre c'est
11%. alors c'est pas 11% d'augmentation
simplement il y a les créations
d'emplois et le retour en emploi des
personnes qui étaient en activité
partielle mais il y a quand même en
moyenne des cas des augmentations qui
sont supérieures à 5% le patronum est
souvent en avant les primes la prime
Macron l'actionnera salarié ce sont des
solutions évidemment pour augmenter les
revenus des collaborateurs mais tout ça
n'est pas pérenne on va pas décrocher un
crédit immobilier auprès de sa banque
avec une prime vous le savez non non en
revanche
au titre du de la valeur il y a des
entreprises qui de manière assez
récurrente et parfois pour des montants
significatifs distribue bonne en ballon
de la participation de l'intéressement
moi j'en parle avec beaucoup de
décontractions dans ma propre entreprise
on a distribué sous cette forme partage
de la valeur sans même prendre en compte
les primes dites Macron 4 fois et demi
plus que de dividendes donc c'est un
package quand même qui se doit d'être
apprécié d'ailleurs quand on embauche
très régulièrement les candidats
demandent ce qu'ils peuvent espérer en
tout cas sous forme d'intéressement et
de participation s'agissant du bien-être
des salariés quelles réponses peut
apporter le patronage et pas je pense
aux droits à la déconnexion qui est
largement souvent en tout cas
ignorer est-ce que c'est ça doit être
désormais un droit fondamental pour le
travailleur enfin c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres c'est alors sur question du
bien-être des salariés alors enquête via
Voice du mois de du mois de juin très
massivement à plus de 70% les salariés
considèrent être bien dans leur
entreprise voilà ça c'est pas moi qui
l'inventes c'est un sondage on va dire
scientifique
non non et puis un autre sondage qui
établit que les priorités pour les
candidats c'est la rémunération c'est
ensuite l'ambiance de travail assez
curieusement on retrouve dans les
profondeurs du classement et ça nous
choque d'une certaine manière la
politique environnementale
l'organisation du travail dont le
télétravail je reviens à votre question
sur le bien-être au travail ça passe par
plus de flexibilité est-ce que c'est de
mettre mot oui mais on peut pas le faire
partout enfin quand vous êtes sur une
chaîne de production d'agroalimentaire
la flexibilité c'est assez compliqué ou
dans l'automobile de la même manière
après dans des
emplois plus administratifs ou parfois
commerciaux on peut imaginer moduler les
horaires je reviens quand même sur cette
histoire de télétravail d'abord pour
dire que les syndicats qui dans un
premier temps était très favorable au
télétravail ont rétropédaler notamment
parce qu'ils pensent et ils ont raison
que sa nuit au collectif de l'entreprise
ensuite parce que votre position aussi
absolument absolument il faut en faire
au cas par cas il faut en faire de
manière concertée de manière pragmatique
mais vous évoquez le droit à la
déconnexion on sait très bien que
les intérêts du télétravail pour les
salariés qui en bénéficient c'est de
pouvoir organiser leur journée comment
concilier ça avec le droit qui prévoit
le droit à la déconnexion quand vous
avez un salarié qui s'arrête et si son
travail le permet entre 10h et midi pour
aller faire des courses du jardinage
s'occuper de ses enfants je ne sais quoi
qui reprend après 20h là le droit à la
déconnexion est opposable donc il va
falloir qu'on fasse converger tous ces
textes et toutes ces organisations
sachant que le pro pour beaucoup de
salariés le pro le professionnel de plus
en plus sur la vie perso est-ce que
c'est pas un sujet ça aussi de bien-être
au travail avec possiblement derrière
des salariés qui sont de plus souvent en
arrêt maladie à des chiffres aussi qui
sont intéressants là-dessus oui alors
assez édifiant donc j'ai réciproquement
la sphère personnelle en quête de plus
en plus sur la sphère et le temps de
travail professionnel on le sait on s'en
a commode on n'empêche pas un salarié de
prendre une communication personnelle
pendant la journée d'envoyer des mails
personnels etc etc donc effectivement ça
ça brouille les lignes ça brouille
l'écart et on ne sait pas très bien
comment légalement gérer la situation là
et donner encore une fois plus
d'autonomie quand c'est possible aux
salariés ça pourrait motiver les troupes
voilà de et c'est plus mettre de leur
agenda de leur emploi du temps avec ou
sans télétravail de le redire les on ne
perçoit pas une démotivation des troupes
il y a des aspirations notamment de la
jeune génération et singulièrement des
jeunes diplômés pour avoir un équilibre
vie personnelle vie professionnelle une
organisation du travail assez différente
de celle qu'on a pu connaître jusqu'à
une période relativement récente on va
dire une organisation fordiste bon voilà
on va gérer ça mais il n'y a pas de
désintérêt ou désaffection pour le
travail contrairement à cette idée
comment dire un peu un peu intellectuel
un peu hors sol qui vendrait que plus
personne ne veut travailler ça n'est pas
vrai il faut qu'il y ait du sens il faut
à nouveau que il y a une organisation du
travail qui correspondent aux
aspirations de cette nouvelle génération
c'est gérable ça veut pas dire qu'elle
ne veut pas travailler cette génération
et leur proposer à cette génération et
d'autres la semaine de quatre jours
parce que quelques boîtes qui l'ont
essayé qui avait l'air assez satisfaite
maladie des salariés plus heureux tout
en étant motivés productif ce pour être
la norme vous êtes contre ou c'est une
façon ou pas de fidéliser un salarié de
l'empêcher de partir non il y a
notamment une entreprise lyonnaise que
je connais très bien LDLC qui était
assez en flèche sur ce sujet là et qui
effectivement sont porte bien il faut
voir tout dépend du secteur d'activité
si vous êtes en production à proprement
parler faire 35 heures en quatre jours
ça peut générer des problèmes de fatigue
ça peut générer des problèmes
y compris d'organisation personnelle ça
n'est pas une demande généralisée de la
part des salariés et le droit du travail
permet en définitive ce type
d'organisation vouloir à tout prix
passer à la semaine de quatre jours ce
sera une erreur terrible mais s'il y a
encore une fois c'est pénurie de main
d'oeuvre Patrick Martin est-ce que
l'employeur devra se montrer plus ouvert
revendications pour attirer retenir
fidéliser enfin tout ça va ensemble les
talents qui étaient accepté d'ailleurs
des choses qui n'auraient pas accepté
auparavant parce que il faut que la
boîte tourne et puis il faut se
développer non il y a deux éléments de
réponse effectivement dans la limite du
raisonnable trouver en matière de
rémunération en matière d'aménagement du
travail et des postes des solutions de
compromis je dirais avec les salariés en
poste mais il y a aussi je le répète
j'insiste beaucoup un effort à faire de
la part des entreprises par exemple sur
l'emploi des seniors par exemple sur
leur capacité à intégrer des candidats
qui sont moins immédiatement
opérationnels parce que moins qualifiées
parce que éloigné du secteur d'activité
et sur la quête de sens j'y reviens
c'est important la quête de sens des
salariés est-ce que ce sujet là est
vraiment pris un bras le corps par les
entreprises bien sûr qui est prêt à bras
le corps mais je réinsiste que c'est pas
dans les priorités aujourd'hui des
salariés mon entreprise est implantée à
travers toute la France je peux vous
dire que selon les territoires et selon
les niveaux de qualification la quête de
sens existe oui partout mais ça n'est
pas nécessairement la priorité des
candidats merci de passer nous voir
Patrick Martin donc président délégué du
manège merci
[Musique]